we are very excited to announce that  first on CBS this morning lin-manuel  Miranda of the creator of the hit  Broadway show Hamilton will join us next  week on the show's opening night in  Puerto Rico the cast has been rehearsing  for its performances on the island where  Miranda traces his family roots and we  will get a backstage tour our David beg  know will also join Miranda and meet  with Puerto Rico residents to learn  about the recovery from Hurricane Maria  Miranda will reprise his lead role for  the first time since he left the  award-winning show in 2016 so make sure  to watch next Friday and every day for  that will be Friday January 11th for our  inside look at the Hamilton production  here on CBS this morning  gosh that makes me want to see it there  I guess we'll get to see it on the show  there you go good good